it's just like getting receiving anal
like the first time you receive anal
you're not gonna climb up no it's true
you let me just say this I'm not a
[ __ ] doctor or a [ __ ] medicine man
you never caught my max off of anal yeah
you can yeah if you're like yeah I mean
Houdini especially as a man cuz that's
where your prostates it's who's know
I've stick my fingers in my bottle
I sometimes like I have not done my job
as a woman there's no pleasure zone
there oh let me find it maybe if you
just allow I'm not gonna allow you to
find it is not there right me it's there
I promise there's a billion dollars in
this room no there is it there is I mean
just because you say something Let Me In
baby let me you're not gonna be in
tonight you let me in i I've stuck my
okay how about this I've taken shits
before how many shits have I had a
millions on million no no how many like
I probably once a day yeah that's good
365 days a week year for how many years
I've been alive for a long time yeah but
it comes out number five minutes in one
shoe and I've had some hard ones yeah
I've had some hard petrified shits a lot
of fiber hard images
never it doesn't feel orgasms because I
have to come in at an angle no there's
no there's nothing there just let me in
baby you know it all supports that Ali
Wong what man trying anal she message oh
that's right that's right oh my god does
it hurt actor yeah Ali Wong's special
just came out on Netflix and I want to
love it I gave it five stars it's just
so refreshing to see like a small
pregnant asian woman talk she said
jungle she wasn't pregnant what'd you do
seven and a half months pregnant once
she's such a G she made me feel so proud
I didn't my own standing ovation in my
living
[Music]